light is one of the basic building
blocks of the universe
I find light to be probably the most
amazing thing in the universe it's so
important in everything I mean it's
everything it's everywhere so it's such
a fundamental part of everything that
exists fundamental and fast the fastest
thing in the cosmos traveling at 186,000
miles per second the song is about 93
million miles away from us so going at
186,000 miles per second that's about
eight minutes but those eight minutes
are just the brief last leg of its
incredible journey
it may have taken the light as much as a
million years to escape from the sun's
raging interior
which means the light we're seeing right
now was created long before our
ancestors left the plains of Africa
when I first learned this fact I was
already a practicing scientist I'd never
really thought about that and on first
glance it just blew me away right now
the light reaching me from the Sun was
produced before there was even human
civilization and yet the minute it gets
to the surface of the Sun it races away
and is here eight minutes after that
it's an incredible idea
the ride that any photon takes to get to
my eyes when I look up at the Sun is an
amazing one that ride starts deep in the
belly of our star if we could open up
the Sun we'd see layers of dense
hydrogen gas hundreds of thousands of
miles deep at at its center the core the
Sun gives birth to light
forged and one of the most violent
reactions in the universe nuclear fusion
the specific nuclear reaction that
powers the Sun is fusion fusion of
hydrogen into helium you take two
hydrogen atoms you Ram them together and
what's left over is a helium atom it
sounds simple enough but it's not